Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is.
Robin for today's episode of beyond Omega level.
We're going way beyond Omega level and discussing one of the cosmic abstracts of
Marvel comics eternity. So we turned it,
he was created by Stanley and Steve Ditko. And first appeared in strange tales.
Number one 38 in 1965 and eternity,
his origin goes back to the origin of the Marvel universe itself in the sense
that in the time before the Marvel multiverse there existed one Sinthian
universe,
mostly composed of a being called the first firmament and the first firmament
would grow lonely and then create for itself companions.
Now some of those companions would turn against the first firmament and a civil
war would erupt between them and the faction that remained loyal to it.
Another rebellious group,
the Celestials ultimately built weapons that were so powerful that they
destroyed the first universe.
And so the first photo then along with the ask for instead of remained loyal to
it and, and not being killed,
fled that universe and the shards of the first universe,
then reformed and to what became the Marvel multiverse.
Now the driving force behind the creation of this multi-verse was eternity,
which would subsequently die and then be reborn several more times as the Marvel
multi-verse is now in its eighth incarnation,
following its destruction at the hands of the beyond hers and secret Wars by
Jonathan Hickman and his following rebirth.
And so as one of the Marvel abstracts eternity's powers are incredibly vast,
so much so that he's nearly omnipotent.
According to [inaudible] eternity is not as powerful as a living tribunal,
but more powerful than the other cosmic abstracts, such as master order.
And Lord chaos.
Eternity has complete mastery over time and space and can manipulate reality on
a multi-vessel level eternity, possesses omniscience,
and is also able to impute others with cosmic awareness as it did when Reed
Richard was being tried for saving the life of Galactus,
which of course people were mad because I'm doing so he basically sealed the
fate of all the planets Galactus would devour in the future,
including the scroll home world,
which resulted in the death of 7 billion scrolls.
So reach put on trial for the desk. Electors had cause,
and is only exonerated after eternity,
as summoned by the watcher and Galactus and grants,
the jurors cosmic awareness so that they know Galactus is a necessary component
of the universe. And since we're dealing with a NY omnipotent entity here,
the best way to get a sense of eternity's power level is probably to go over
some of the most impressive things we've seen him do in several appearances.
So that's what we're going to do here.
Starting with looking at a character that's been defeated by eternity.
And one of his earliest appearances eternity is challenged by Dormamuu one of
the strongest,
if not the strongest Wheeler of dark magic in the Marvel universe,
even so Dormamuu who himself is well beyond.
Omega level is easily dispatched by eternity.
Eternity even makes the comment during a later meeting between the two
characters that Dormamuu is not even significant enough for eternity to concern
himself with.
There is an instance later on when Dormamuu would combine his strength with that
of his sister Umar. And it said that after doing that,
he managed to defeat eternity and steal his power to remake the universe.
According to his will. I mean, I kind of take this with a grain of salt though,
because it happens like off panel and it just doesn't seem consistent with how
these characters are typically written. But even though it's kind of an outlier,
I did want to include it for the sake of providing as much information as I
could, uh, after one of eternity's battles with Dormamuu,
he was significantly weakened, which allowed another of, one of Dr. Strange,
his perennial enemies nightmare to somehow blind eternity with chains of pure
cosmic force, which allows nightmare to begin reshaping reality.
Now eternity is eventually freed when nightmare in juggernaut who'd been trapped
in the Crimson,
cosmos unwittingly hit his chains with their mystic energies because juggernaut
apparently learned how to cast spells during his time and exile.
Although we Trinity States that he could have freed himself at any time,
which sounds like the most eternity thing for eternity to say, right?
Cause he's like a really proud being, you know, and it's like, well, I mean,
you know, I, I would've freed myself eventually, but once freed eternity,
effortlessly banishes nightmare and juggernaut into oblivion and then undoes all
the changes nightmare had made to reality. Once again,
displaying his own reality warping abilities,
no another good measuring stick that we have available to show us the vast power
that eternity has was something that we covered recently on this series.
The story of Abraxis. Now,
if you didn't watch that video and you don't know who Abraxis is,
he is another cosmic abstract and as the embodiment of destruction and the
multi-verse, he's basically eternity's opposite,
but a Brock SIS has always existed within eternity and to keep them in check,
we got Galactus. However,
as the various versions of Galactus throughout the multi-verse are killed
Abraxis is able to escape and wreak havoc across the multi-verse.
No one have brought to this sets his sights on the six one six universe,
the main Marvel universe Reed Richards knew there was no other alternative than
to destroy all of reality with the ultimate notifier and then subsequently
remake it.
And so the fact that eternity is able to confine an entity as powerful as a
Braxton within himself,
and is also responsible for the creation of multiple Galactus in multiple
universes, shows us just how powerful eternity is. Now.
There are limits to eternity's power. For instance,
he was defeated by Thanos when he wielded the infinity gauntlet and was also
imprisoned by the Magnus in his quest to assemble the infinity stones,
eternity would however,
merge with a sister infinity to take the power of the infinity stones away from
the magazine and when to be honors destroy the Marvel multi-verse in the
timeline's out storyline. They take out eternity in the process. However,
as I stated earlier, eternity is resurrected along with a Marvel multi-verse.
Now recently eternity was in prison. Once again,
this time by the first ferment who had actually been allowed entry into the
multi-verse due to his weakened state,
as a result of being destroyed and recreated,
it should also be noted that it was not merely an aspect of eternity that was in
prison, which is what we usually see interacting with human characters,
but the entire entity of eternity itself,
which embodies all of life in the multi-verse. Now,
eternity is eventually free by the combined efforts of blue Marvel and the
ultimate, and then battles the first firmament who infects them with a virus.
Now, once the virus is purged,
eternity remembers his true nature and summons to his side,
a group he refers to as the ultimate ultimate the embodiments of the multi
versus past.
Now each of these ultimate Ultimate's are extremely powerful entities.
One being the originator of magic, one,
the inventor of science and one being eternity, sister, self, infinity,
and eternity was able to summon them to aside instantaneously. And so,
although eternity is not omnipotent and has been defeated,
he usually overcomes whatever defeats. He suffers,
even to the point of resurrecting. Each time he's destroyed.
And since eternity is the embodiment of all life and the multi-verse,
his resurrection means that reality, as we know, it can continue to exist.
So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end. Yeah.
Needless to say, eternity's incredibly powerful, right?
This is a wildly powerful being. And I kind of figured you guys all knew that,
right? I mean,
he's like the top tier of the cosmic entities in any one universe, but yeah,
it's kind of nuts. What would that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end. If you guys are new here to college,
explain the mission.
You guys have the sub button to become part of the rod core.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible].